[Musique]
je me lève je pense à nasser
pendant 18 mois j'étais son ombre
[Musique]
c'est un gros poisson
c'était parmi les objectifs majeurs du
renseignement français
le soir je m'endors en pensant à la serm
nasser c'est le pseudo donner à un
terroriste la cible de nora laquelle
pour brut
je vais vous raconter l'histoire de cet
agent c'est la première femme à avoir
intégré un groupe d'élite
anti-terroriste la source
pendant des années elle a espionné des
groupes d'islamistes radicaux
nora c'est le parcours d'une française
musulmane et filles d'immigrés en lutte
contre les sabres radical
les parents sont arrivés en france au
début des années 70 il y avait le plein
emploi pour les immigrés donc mon père a
saisi sa chance et il a décidé de venir
de tunisie
j'ai grandi dans une loge de gardienne
ma mère était gardienne d'immeuble
[Musique]
c'était plutôt un logement on va dire
insalubres je pense qu'à ce moment là
j'étais un peu j'avais la rage moi
j'avais la rage du pourquoi pourquoi ça
m'arrive à moi pourquoi est-ce que je
suis pas comme les autres que mes
parents m'aident pas à étudier à me
construire et donc j'avais beaucoup de
souffrance et je savais pas où la m et
j'ai réussi à canaliser toute cette
énergie en pratiquant la boxe française
[Musique]
bon professeur était quelqu'un déjà
physiquement assez robuste voilà et puis
à brut
c'est quelqu'un qui souriait jamais et
c'est très très difficile parce que
c'est le type de personne qui vous dit
toujours que vous avez beaucoup de
chemin à faire avant d'être le meilleur
[Musique]
c'était le soir après un assaut que j'ai
eu avec mon prof de boxe et qui ment
fait laminer je me suis dit il faut que
je rattrape le coup fort j'avais quand
même prendre un verre pour dire où je
suis quand même sympa comme fille même
si voilà je m' a explosé il a découvert
à ce moment là que j'étais étudiante en
philosophie est bon alors il m'a ça fait
rire tout le monde
jb coûte c'est tout tu utilises moque de
moi mais qu'est ce que tu fais toi et là
en fait il poursuivra toujours il a fait
son il a pris sa veste aviateur
il m'a dit regarde mais tu dis à
personne sinon ça va mal se finir pour
toi il a fait comme ça et là j'ai vu un
glock est en fait j'étais très choquée
c'est avec une arme et là il me dit mais
moi je suis à la berri brigade de
répression et l'intervention je n'étais
pas rassuré parce que j'avais j'ai déjà
vécu par procuration la mort de malik
oussékine c'est donc ce matin entre 1h30
et 2h que malik oussékine 22 ans
étudiant à dauphine a été victime
d'affrontements entre des manifestants
et les brigades spéciales motocycliste
de la préfecture de police
tous les témoignages concordent le jeune
homme a été violemment frappé par trois
policiers semble-t-il
vous voyez des infirmiers en train de
faire des gestes de premiers secours
c'est un moment très poignant et en plus
et le film la haine de kassovitz qui a
fini une fois pour toutes de me faire me
dire que finalement la police s'était
pas le meilleur à nos meilleurs amis
j'étais assez naïve pour croire que à
partir du moment où moi n'aura lakehal
j'allais rentrer dans la police
j'allais pouvoir changer les choses
c'est à dire réparer les injustices et
pacifier les rapports entre la
population et à police donc je suis
affecté à l'école de police de reims
[Musique]
il a fallu de quelques petites semaines
pour que déjà je m'accroche avec un
formateur on disait alors
nora qu'est ce qu'on va faire ce week
end alors je suis sûr que vous allez
manger du couscous c'est ça faire un peu
de danse du ventre
je ressors en larmes
[Musique]
déjà d'une j'ai le droit d'être arraf
j'ai le droit d'être musulmane ai je le
droit d'être française et le droit
d'être laïc et j'ai le droit d'être tout
ça en même temps
[Musique]
à partir du 11 septembre 2001 tout
bascule dans le monde mais aussi dans
mon parcours
[Musique]
à
au sein de la police mes collègues ne me
considère plus comme la beurette ou
l'arabe mais je deviens la musulmane ce
sont les premières fois où par exemple
dans les salles de repos on pose des
questions à sabathia a tu pratiques mais
est ce que tu manges du port les
questions auxquelles on se pose est
absolument pas avant
nous tous
les services de renseignement sont
maintenant persuadés que le terrorisme
peut frapper par tour plusieurs
islamistes franco marocains ont été
arrêtés en début de semaine en région
parisienne c'est à paris ce matin que
les policiers de la dst ont opéré un
coup de filet dans les milieux
islamistes
[Musique]
m
à cette époque-là des renseignements
généraux est décidé de créer des groupes
de recherche spécifiquement attachée à
la lutte contre l'islam radical déjà
dans les banlieues donc un de façon très
pragmatique il avait été décidé de
recruter des gens d'origine maghrébine
on m'explique lors des tests que je vais
être la première fille à intégrer ce
service qui est la source la section
opérationnelle et recherche spécialisés
donc c'était le service d'élite des
renseignements généraux
six hommes sont chargés de traquer les
réseaux terroristes en france
[Musique]
leur travail consiste à faire des
filatures surveillances infiltration
dans les milieux islamistes radicaux
là c'était vraiment de la surveillance
au plus près c'est à dire que nos
missions c'était on nous donnait en gros
une photo où on nous donnait une adresse
et à partir de là il fallait
retracer les activités de l'objectif ses
contacts ses habitudes ma mission était
de suivre tous les faits et gestes de
nasser de cette époque là c'était
c'était parmi les objectifs majeurs du
renseignement français
c'était un théoricien quelqu'un de très
intelligent plutôt âgés et qui fédérait
énormément pendant 18 mois j'étais son
ombre j'allais oublier a l'air très
simplement et c'est très compliqué parce
que sur 18 mois
il faut ne pas être repéré donc faut
s'habiller de telle manière quand il va
dans une mosquée il faut aller
s'habiller de tel autre quand il va
aller voir ses copains en bas de la cité
après plusieurs mois de filatures nora
est démasqué par nasser dans le jargon
des rg ont dit qu'elles aient des
tranchées c'était un des moments les
plus difficiles de ma vie en fait il a
tourné le dos et puis il est venu vers
moi avec trois de ses acolytes qui
revenait du pakistan et là j'ai eu la
peur de ma vie j'ai mis mon arme absolue
à proximité et là il me dit bon écoute
ne s'est pas de faire la maligne on t'a
vu on connaît déjà tout ton équipe
on les a déjà des tranchées depuis un
petit moment et le gam dit t'inquiète
pas moi je suis là pour toi
il m'a dit de toutes les façons tu ne
seras jamais française parce que il ne
t'aime pas pour nous quoi qu'il se passe
je sera toujours une musulmane
du coup moi j'étais sincèrement j'étais
au bout de ma vie j'ai vu le premier bus
qui passait je suis rentré dedans j'ai
même pas où j'allais les portes se sont
fermées et j'ai senti je pense
sincèrement un litre d'eau tombées comme
ça et je sais ce que j'ai compris ce que
c'était que la peur
dans ce cas particulier avec naceur il y
avait un projet d'attentât qui a été
déjouée grâce à nous le travail de ces
fonctionnaires jamais été reconnu à sa
juste valeur
pour que parents devront trouver normal
de leur faire prendre des risques
on demande souvent aux musulmans de
france de faire entendre leur voix quand
il ya des attentats mais au sein de
l'administration au sein de la police si
vous avez des flics musulmans qui font
ça tous les jours
il est engagement là est passé
totalement inaperçu quelque part on l'a
sauvé la france et les français